vaccination who knew a few years ago
that we would get to a situation so
absurd and so insane in the united
states when it comes to vaccines
because of the pandemic today our deep
dive into vaccines and vaccine mandates
all right i want to sort of get ahead of
this story and spend some time today
talking about
supposed biden mask mandates because the
amount of disinformation that we're
already seeing if it's at all a preview
is going to absolutely explode when joe
biden is actually sworn in as president
of the united states on january 20th so
to go back a little bit right wingers
have been warning even during the
campaign joe biden will lock everyone in
their homes joe biden will be a dictator
with masks and all sorts of other things
if he becomes president and over the
last 48 to 72 hours we heard two
different things that are not the same
thing very important
we heard from dr anthony fauci that
indeed joe biden plans to do a hundred
day mask initiative
and within that there will be a piece
that is a federal mass mandate now when
you hear federal mass mandate many
people imagine something that is very
different from what we're actually going
to get so let me say this in the
clearest terms possible
joe biden nor any president
can
mandate a national mask wearing
law where everybody's forced to wear a
mask outside of their homes i've already
addressed this so listen very closely to
what i'm going to say
what joe biden can do
is address the nation from the oval
office and ask people to wear masks he
can call the governors of 50 states and
ask them to put in place mask mandates
which governors can do in various areas
massachusetts governor charlie baker is
an example earlier this week he's a
republican announced that there will be
a mask mandate in workplaces in
massachusetts we got an email from our
office tenant where everybody's working
from home anyway right now but they said
everybody's got to wear a mask per
charlie baker's order
governors can do that given states
rights and yet there's a ton of
headlines today which are very confusing
in talking about a joe biden nationwide
mask mandate suggesting the federal
government will force everybody to wear
a mask so let me explain what's going on
as the president of the united states
part of the
a federal government joe biden plans to
issue a mask mandate that includes
federal buildings
as well as airplanes trains and buses
which are regulated by the federal
department of transportation that's it
that's the mandate that's what the
president can do via executive order and
in just about every state masks are
already required in all of those places
now i do have some federal government
employee friends who work in red states
who have told me you know the the
equivalent agency in massachusetts and
in california you've got to wear a mask
in my office for that same agency in a
red state our boss has not mandated
masks that will change based on this
mask mandate for federal buildings but
it will change very little else so
before we go crazy misstating what this
is
joe biden's mandate will apply only to
federal buildings and transportation
vehicles
regulated by the d.o.t beyond that any
mass guidelines from biden will merely
be guidelines they will be requests they
will be proposals
it will be up to your governor to decide
what to do that's it now dr fauci has
said
wearing masks for a hundred days is a
good idea it will be up to the people
and governors ultimately to decide what
it is they want to do for people who
have been wearing masks for months
already
this is going to be much ado about
nothing consider that you know there is
now a light at the end of the tunnel
let's actually work together to start
getting past this if we can start here's
my trajectory if we can start
vaccinating five to seven percent of our
population each month
maybe that includes december maybe we
only get you know one two percent done
in december in january we get five to
seven percent february etc this means in
six months we could have somewhere
between 30 and 42 of the population
vaccinated plus the five to ten percent
who will have recovered from the virus
we don't yet know how uniform uh
immunity is when you recover
there's the idea that if you have a very
light case your immunity may not be as
robust as if you recover from a more
serious case so we don't know exactly
but we could be heading towards a
roughly 50 percent level of immunity by
may first maybe by may 15th that won't
be the end but it will be a dramatically
better situation we will also likely at
that point have cheap at-home tests so
like for me if i imagine hey i might be
able to order 50 or 100 of these cheap
at home rapid tests
i've been very cautious but i've
continued going to the grocery store i
go to the post office during the summer
i was hanging out outdoors with friends
eating outdoors at restaurants if we had
on may 15th may 1st may 15th
50 immunity and these at-home tests i
would likely be ready to say for example
hey here's a group of six friends we've
all been working from home
if we all do a rapid test
i would be comfortable if we're all
negative hanging out indoors maintaining
a reasonable amount of distance uh
assuming we're at 50 immunity with these
tests okay i mean listen it's it's it's
not perfect
but we're talking about may june and to
be clear with half the country
vaccinated now you also have to remember
there is a lag time on vaccination
immunity
and what i mean by that is the time
until vaccinated people actually reduce
the number of deaths could is is weeks
and what i mean by that is on day one
you get dose number one dose number one
confers some immunity but not all so
that starts to have an effect
day 22 21 days later you get your second
dose and then seven days after that you
would be considered to be you know
there's a 95 chance that you were immune
so by day 28 to 29
you
ideally
are no longer
getting other people sick who you might
have gotten sick were you not vaccinated
since it takes 20 days in general from
when someone catches the virus to when
they die if they're going to die
vaccinated individuals
will not be fully effective at reducing
deaths
for 48 days we won't see the impact on
deaths of a vaccinated individual for up
to 48 days now we know that after dose
one you can be as much as 70 or even 75
percent likely
to to be immune so these are all
confidence intervals but i think you
understand the point that there's a lag
time
um
before which vaccination uh is not
really doing doing that much to stop
cases and to stop death so the the point
is this is a process
and it there is every indication that by
may 1 may 15 we will be in a better
situation masks will likely be required
in just as many places as they are today
uh but we are now we had 2 960 people
die yesterday were essentially at a 9 11
every day so rather than the point is
rather than lying about what joe biden
plans to do
let's work together and start getting
past this
we have a good uh
court decision
to tell you today regarding the pandemic
and uh guidelines there is a dallas
county judge that has ruled against
texas governor greg abbott's move to ban
mass mandates in the state now
you if if you're watching from another
country for example and you're in a
country that makes a little more sense
than the united states thanks to the
republican party
you might assume
if governors are going to get involved
with mass mandates you would think
governors would say hey i'm not leaving
it up to the to the local level
all schools must um have a mass
requirement in place for the time being
for the upcoming fall semester um in
order to prevent the spread but you
would be wrong the involvement of
governors in mass mandates particularly
in red states places like florida
florida is a very 50 50 state but with
ron desantis the republican governor
texas with greg abbott the involvement
of governors has been to ban
mask mandates or at least to try to to
ban vaccine requirements or at least to
try to and a dallas county judge says no
you can't enforce it you can't do it you
can't ban mass mandates if that is what
municipalities or schools or whoever
wants to do judge tanya parker sided
with dallas county judge clay jenkins on
wednesday issuing a temporary injunction
against abbott's ban on mask mandates
the move will allow jenkins mask order
in addition to similar policies in other
local school districts to remain in
place for the time being jenkins will
now have the ability to issue penalties
to individuals who don't comply with the
county's policy which requires that
masks are worn in businesses schools and
county-owned buildings
parker wrote in the ruling that jenkins
proved that dallas county residents will
suffer probable imminent and irreparable
injury through county judge jenkins
being precluded from exercising his
authority to mandate masks in public so
what what the decision is and sometimes
it's like
was the was something banned or was the
ban banned or did they ban bans on
banned okay you get it
the decision here is
the governor can't ban
mask requirements as a as an umbrella
uh decision or or direction
the controversy in dallas began when
commissioner j.j koch filed a lawsuit
against jenkins earlier this month after
being removed from a courtroom for
refusing to wear a mask jenkins
responded by filing a lawsuit against
abbott over an executive order he signed
that banned mass mandates uh if you
think this is the end of the road for
this it is not the temporary injunction
will likely be appealed to the fifth
court of appeals in dallas
and then to the supreme texas supreme
court before a final ruling is made
abbott's office said in a statement it
believes
in the state attorney general's ability
to defend the executive order
imagine for a moment
not only the money that could be saved
but potentially the number of infections
that could be prevented
hospitalizations that could be prevented
and some number of deaths that could be
prevented
if instead of focusing on banning public
safety guidelines
instead the texas governor and his
office focused on encouraging
vaccination
encouraging safety protocol and working
to actually get beyond the pandemic
rather than these pathetic shows about
liberty and freedom and whatever else
but unfortunately like we see it as a
not only a waste of time but it's
something that's bad for public health
the republican party
particularly in these red states is
about obstructing
um
bringing down anything and anyone who is
trying to make a positive impact under
the guise of so-called freedom and
liberty
and unless they start losing
they are probably going to continue
doing this for a long time because as
i've said before they've completely
abandoned policy uh and if you think
this is the only thing that greg abbott
is doing no yesterday actually executive
order ga39
this is a vaccine mandate ban
and the idea here is to prohibit vaccine
mandates and vaccine passports subject
to legislative action so while this is
getting struck down he's trying to
prevent vaccine mandates and vaccine
requirements and they claim to be about
liberty freedom and not regulating
business but yet they're going out of
their way to say we need the government
to ban a private business from making
whatever decision is right for them
normally these are the people who say if
something is the right decision for a
business or even if it's the wrong
decision but they think it's the right
decision they should be free to make
that mistake or to take the correct
action
uh except when they want to say hey you
know what it would be really bad for our
business for unvaccinated people to come
in and start spreading the virus so
we're going to require vax proof of
vaccination oh no no no
now we need the full power of government
to regulate these people not surprising
they've been hypocrites for a very very
long time
uh and hopefully i mean we're we're sort
of in a race here not only against the
virus but we're in a legis in a um uh
a judicial race of sorts where we're
constantly needing courts to weigh in
and to prevent destructive actions often
self-destructive actions and if you want
to take a look at where texas may be
heading just look at the coveted
hellscape that is florida uh look at
mississippi look at alabama texas
benefits from the fact that their health
care infrastructure
is better than mississippi and alabama
mississippi and alabama are absolutely
the worst and look at what's happening
in their icus but it is hitting texas as
well as i covered yesterday
three independent emergency rooms in
texas have had to close
because the uh organization that runs
them needed to take all of their staff
and bring them to other facilities
overloaded with covid so as we've said
before if you get into a car accident in
texas you're vaccinated
um you you have a health issue that it's
not even coveted related you get into a
car accident there are now three ers
which simply will not be available
because all of the staff needed to be
brought elsewhere to deal with covid
overwhelmingly in hospitalized
unvaccinated patients and this is going
to continue we'll take a quick break
after the break i do want to talk about
uh a bunch of you sent me these clips
from an anti-vaccine rally in new york
city
it's scary it's scary uh you know it's
entertaining and it's cartoonish but
it's also really real really scary we'll
take a look at those videos right after
this short break don't forget that the
best way to support the david pakman
show is by becoming a member which gives
you access to the daily bonus show the
regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
okay this is really great stuff a
question i've been asking for weeks now
is
if you are opposed to the approved
covid19 vaccine being required anywhere
why aren't you opposed to a requirement
for the chickenpox vaccine
or the polio
or mmr
or hepatitis or whatever the case may be
fox news host chris wallace confronted
the republican
nebraska governor pete ricketts about
exactly that question now ricketts is
again
uh
loudly coming out against everything joe
biden is trying to do on coronavirus
requirements including most recently the
vaccine mandates and requirements for
employers and others but the very same
pete ricketts is fine with tons of other
vaccines this is fascinating stuff let's
watch and listen to the multiple things
that ricketts says because we're going
to break them down one by one in a
moment to attend school in your state of
nebraska children must be vaccinated
against a number of diseases let me put
them up on the screen
they must be vaccinated against
diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis that's the dtp
shot that kids get
polio measles mumps and rubella
hepatitis b and chickenpox
why
are those mandates that parents in your
state must comply with
and do comply with routinely
why is it that they're not
so objectionable and such a violation
beautiful personal freedom but biden's
vaccine mandates are
well for all those that you just listed
there's a long history that parents have
had the opportunity to see how those
things have been implemented
so there's a long history is not
actually an argument it might sound like
an argument but it's not actually an
argument he's not explaining why that
should matter maybe if he tried to
explain he could give us something
substantive and we might be convinced or
not but alone that's not an argument and
there's still a lot of people out there
who don't know what to trust and in fact
this is really an outcome of what the
cdc has done because they flip-flop on
so many issues whether it's mass or
whether you have to mask after vaccine
and so forth okay so then he says lots
of people don't know who to trust
that's also not an argument because the
question is in either case with all the
vaccines they're approved by the same
body
and then the cdc has flip-flopped
this one i'm very sick of they act like
when the cdc changes their view based on
more data
they act like it's just changing your
mind about a movie you like i mean
listen one day you like the movie you're
in a different mood the next day you
don't like it the cdc uses science which
is a process with with a self-correcting
mechanism built in it becomes ideally
more accurate over time and it's not an
argument against one vaccine but not
another remember the question was why is
this vaccine requirement not okay and
that one is so it it's in particular not
not an argument against that there's
just a lot of people out there who don't
know who to trust right now and so by
having the government force it on you're
not building the trust where we have the
trust with those other vaccines now
remember it's also not being forced your
employer can choose to let people test
out each week instead of being
vaccinated or not if your employer
doesn't want to
as republicans like pete ricketts want
employers to be able to do
this is a process going to take time to
bring people along and that's why it
should be a personal choice and not
something mandated by the government but
but forgive me sir i'm old enough that i
remember when the polio vaccine first
came out uh a lot of us and certainly
our parents viewed it as a blessing and
immediately i lived in new york state at
that time the state mandated that we all
get the polio vaccine right so you know
we're in the middle of a pandemic there
is a new vaccine that donald trump was
largely responsible for it's been
approved full approval by the fda
again if if
polio vaccine is okay for for parents
and they have to comply with it to send
their kid to school why not chris
wallace is doing a good job here for
a lot of people not just kids
the vaccine for uh for this disease
yeah and i think this is very different
from polio that has very devastating
effects and certainly we know if you're
older you know 65 years and older that's
where 83 percent of our deaths in
nebraska so then he drops in well polio
is devastating well then talk about
another condition i mean the the death
rate of chickenpox is really low it's
one per 100 000
if you look at slightly older kids it's
six per 100 thousand it's very
contagious but it's not very deadly so
the point here is he has no good answer
and this is a question we've been asking
for a while look at all these other
requirements for vaccination they're
only talking of most 99.9 of them are
only talking about the covid vaccine
requirement they are pathetic they don't
have an answer that they're able to
articulate if they can come up with an
actual substantive explanation
i would gladly review it and think about
it and maybe they will convince me okay
this is really great for weeks now i've
been reminding you every time we talk
about fox news criticizing various
vaccine requirements at different
companies i've been reminding you fox
news has a stricter vaccine mandate than
the one that joe biden has proposed for
companies with a hundred or more
employees as we watched tucker carlson
and laura ingram and dan bongino
criticize the requirements outlined by
joe biden that all sorts of different
companies have adopted sports teams
airlines other organizations fox news
hosts would not mention hey our mandate
here at fox is even stricter
joe biden said get vaccinated or test
weekly fox news is doing get vaccinated
or test daily and wear a mask around
other employees if you're not vaccinated
fox news host wouldn't mention it they
would just talk about vaccine mandates
it's terrible they wouldn't mention by
the way we work it's even stricter
last week during his cnn town hall which
we covered live joe biden actually
brought this up joe biden actually said
hey you know uh
there's the cynical hypocritical
fox coverage of vaccination
they have a mandate okay so take a look
at joe biden mentioning that you know
what i find fascinating
i turn on fox to find out how popular i
am
but
how are you doing there i'm doing very
well i think i'm at three percent
favorable but
but all kidding aside one of the things
i find you realize they mandate
vaccinations
at fox headquarters yeah
i find that mildly fascinating you kind
of mildly mildly fascinating
um now that is absolutely true
uh they mandate with the option of
testing out just like joe biden proposed
except at fox if you want to test out
you've got to test daily instead of
weekly
this now pushed fox news into needing to
comment on it they can't just pretend
it's not going on and their reaction is
just to lie and play a meaningless
semantic game that is completely bogus
so take a look at what the fox and
friends crew said the next morning about
their own mandate you missed information
he said about fox he thought it was i
think it's funny that fox has a vaccine
mandate you have a testing option at fox
so what he said is totally inaccurate we
don't have a mandate we have a protocol
right that's a little different so what
you tell the president we don't have a
mandate here
says steve ducey we have
a protocol why
because you can test instead of getting
vaccinated but that's exactly what joe
biden proposed joe biden said vaccinate
or test weekly and fox says vaccinate or
test daily and wear a mask and here's
why
it's not a mandate but it's a protocol
is so silly just look at what the words
mean a mandate is an official order or
commission to do something well joe
biden's order is you vaccinator test
weekly so by that definition it's a
mandate fox news's order is vaccinator
test daily that's a mandate by this
definition it's a mandate
now a protocol
is the accepted or established code of
procedure or behavior in a group
organization or situation okay so let's
look at protocol joe biden's established
code of procedure
is that you vaccinate or you test weekly
it's a protocol fox news's established
code of procedure is you vaccinate or
you test daily it's a protocol they are
both mandates of a particular protocol
this is meaningless semantic trash and i
tweeted about this over the weekend i
said so apparently biden's required
vaccine or required weekly testing is a
mandate but fox news's required vaccine
or required daily testing is a protocol
and i received a ton of really great
responses
but one twitter user diddytrek1
lays it out the way that i did here
saying a protocol and a mandate are
synonymous
both mean something has to happen policy
is also synonymous with mandate and
protocol
and that is exactly correct so this
shouldn't surprise us these are just
hypocrites these are people who mostly
want to keep their jobs even as dan
bongino
was saying
i make what dan bongino's thing with um
i think it was cumulus radio networks
although maybe he has a show on fox and
a show with a radio network it might be
cumulus he was saying listen i'm
vaccinated but i'm against any vaccine
requirements so i may quit my job here
depending on what happens
he hasn't mentioned the fact that he's
also an employee at fox which has one of
the strictest requirements now there are
some employers that have gone further
and they've said we just don't want to
deal with the testing
um or we don't want to offer a testing
option we just want everybody vaccinated
that's it and certainly that's their
prerogative and something they can
legally do
that's not actually what joe biden
proposed for companies of 100 or more
employees and what fox news has gone out
of its way to do is something that's
even stricter i have a friend who
recently started work at a
at a west coast west coast based startup
and
during the hiring process
even right there when you apply it says
everybody on our staff has to be fully
vaccinated this allows us to do
in-person events where we can we just
test everybody on the way in and and
we've got these two layers everybody's
vaccinated and tested we can do stuff
and they they do do things just don't
apply if you're not willing if you're
not willing to be fully vaccinated by
the time you start just don't apply and
much like hey this job requires you to
work two overnights a week oh i don't
want that i'm not going to apply fine
you're being you're told up front
um that is something companies can
certainly do but that's not even what's
actually being discussed when we talk
about the joe biden requirements so it's
great that joe biden mentioning it
during the town hall thursday
pushed fox hosts to start talking about
it their reaction is so bogus their
explanation is so pathetic and and and
cement it's semantics at the end
um it shouldn't really surprise us and
we'll see my guess is that there's going
to be more commentary on this from them
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind-the-scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow i'm
really glad to see that more and more
a fox news hosts are being confronted
with the hypocrisy of their going
completely crazy about the vaccine
mandates that are being put in place by
various companies while not mentioning
that fox news itself actually has a
stricter mandate than that which most
companies have and that which was
proposed by joe biden for companies of
100 or more employees so yesterday we
had this clip from fox and friends where
they completely unbelievably said we
don't have a mandate we have a protocol
we looked at the definition of the word
mandate we looked at the definition of
the word protocol and we determined uh
they have both it's it's the same thing
it's a distinction without a difference
it's a difference without a distinction
whatever word or phrase you want to
apply to it it was bs and it was not
believable today we're going to go and
look at another one of these
confrontations and this one is with
tucker carlson
now this one's really interesting
because tucker carlson has been one of
the most sort of prominent
purveyors
of the attacks on vaccine requirements
even saying the vaccines don't even
really seem to work and the vaccines
might have killed thousands of people
and all these different things media
matters has a great article on this fox
personalities trying to distance
themselves from fox's vaccine mandate
even though fox news's requirements for
unvaccinated workers are stricter than
those recommended by the biden
administration
network hosts continue to attack
vaccination policies and compliance
protocols fox personalities and guests
have insisted the mandates and testing
requirements are akin to jim crow laws
apartheid
eugenics
forced sterilization and discrimination
against those affected by hiv aids
the biden administration policies fox
has spent months demonizing
require companies with 100 or more
employees to ensure that staff is
vaccinated or test weekly
fox corporation's policy is get
vaccinated or test daily
and enter your status into an online
portal more than 90 percent of fox
employees report being vaccinated
okay so now
um
[Music]
this is great this is a clip from save
the nation vince and jason and they
bring this to tucker carlson on october
13th he does this maniacal laugh take a
look at this okay so i i have a question
here about fox news um yeah
you said fox news has no vaccine mandate
but according to newsweek the company
requires unvaccinated employees to
submit to daily covid testing which is
stricter than biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing right in
businesses that employ more than 100
people is fox news denying the civil
liberties of its employees by being
stricter than president biden fair i
don't know i mean you should probably
ask newsweek it sounds like they got a
pretty precise handle on what's
happening
right so that's not a serious answer all
right but let's continue hey if it's
wrong let me know if i'm wrong no
yeah
it's
it's completely wrong as i noted the
other night
um i'm not
you know so what is the policy
so that's that's just that's just you
know bs
as an employee he could speak to his
understanding of the policy he's
subjected to i mean he's subjected to
the policy so you don't have to speak
for the company because i don't run the
company and i'm not
you know i'm just an employee of the
company um
my personal press tell us as an employee
the policy you've been subjected to and
that you've agreed to reference is that
fox news
would
you know
make a statement about what its policies
are but i think like a lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and a lot with
much higher mortality rates than covid19
true and you know there's hiv of course
there's tuberculosis of course there are
a bunch of different varieties for
hepatitis which have killed
many hundreds of thousands of americans
over the years et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and employers are not empowered in fact
they're not allowed to ask employees
what their status is are you hiv
positive really can you be test should
we test people so notice that this is
this is now
a gish gallop
okay
there's no vaccine for hiv
first and foremost okay
secondly we're talking about asking
employees vaccination status not disease
status
number three
hiv is far less contagious than covet
it's a sexually transmitted disease it's
a
i hope people understand the way in
which this is a verbal ink plot there's
no real substantive answer here based on
their sexual but hiv isn't a
communicable disease in the same way
like you can't you can't sneeze on
somebody and give them hiv right because
he has killed has killed tens of
millions oh yeah now that's a different
now now notice how the goal posts are
different
the death toll of hiv over
40 years now is different than how
contagious it is
it also i mean
you can't just walk by someone and they
sneeze and you have hiv um this is
really i don't think tucker is this
stupid so i think this is just bad faith
i don't i don't doubt that but you can't
it's not a communicable disease in the
same way you have to have sex or share
blood correct
well sure at which point would you
transmit it so it is by definition
communicable yeah and he said it's not
communicable in the same way and he's
right not and it's communicable in the
same way
that's my point just to be clear
i am totally opposed to asking anybody
his hiv status
so now
look at what he's doing
this is a it's really a clinic in
disinformation now tucker is saying he's
against the thing he mentioned
which is not even analogous to covet
vaccination status he now says
covet he so he's he said covet
vaccination status is analogous to
asking hiv status and he's against he's
not saying ask people hiv step we're not
even talking about the same thing
anymore the first question was
doesn't your company have a stricter
policy than the one biden suggests which
tucker got out of by saying
listen i don't i don't speak for fox
news
i'm totally opposed to asking his
prostate cancer status
or
what prostate cancer now now we're in
now we're in lulu you know looney land
uh when we now with pr
prostate cancer hiv is communicable
through flu
through sexual contact sexual fluids
blood
now with prostate cancer what are we
even talking about this has nothing to
do with medical privacy his you know
latest blood sugar levels are i mean we
have hipaa laws for a reason so i'm
hired to do a job
and now now raising hipaa hipaa has
absolutely nothing to do with this
whatsoever so
look at the way in which tucker is
unable to give any serious answer
fox's policy is stricter than the one
biden proposes tucker first says i don't
speak for fox news no but you're an
employee you could tell us what they
told you you could tell us what decision
you made about going with it in order to
continue working there that's number one
he doesn't answer
then he goes into
hiv
then he goes into hiv status versus
vaccination status
then prostate cancer
then hipaa this is not about hipaa hipaa
has to do with the transmission of
medical records and privacy by medical
providers we're off the deep end folks
so
look at how quickly he fell apart under
just basic questioning all right this is
super interesting you guys may remember
we've been covering this incredible
double standard this incredible
hypocrisy where fox news hosts and many
in right-wing media have been slamming
the joe biden
vaccine mandate protocol requirement in
which a large employers with more than
100 employees have to either
get their employees vaccinated
get proof that their employees are
vaccinated or they have to test their
unvaccinated employees once a week now
fox news has implemented a much stricter
protocol where you either need to be
vaccinated or tested daily and you're
required to wear a mask when working on
location in certain areas so the fox
protocol the fox requirement the fox
guidelines call it whatever you want it
is stricter stricter than the ones
outlined by joe biden
another fox host was confronted about
this this is really interesting this is
pete seth who's a big anti-biden guy big
bomb thrower and he was interviewed by
mediaite's editor-in-chief aidan
mclaughlin and when he was confronted
with this double standard
where hegseth is regularly railing on
the biden protocol but fox says his
employer's protocol is stricter
he
first wasn't really sure what to say
then he resorted to attacking mediaite
which might not surprise you let's take
a look at this very instructive
there was a vaccine or test requirement
at the patriot awards which is very
similar to the policy at fox news do you
have an issue with fox news having a
policy like that which is effectively
the same as biden's vaccine mandate for
big businesses
uh i uh
you don't you're not mandated to get the
vaccine because you can get a test right
now remember
it's the same thing with joe biden
you're not mandated to get the vaccine
because you can get a test
i'm not in charge of it uh i don't make
the calls but
either you you have the option to get a
test so you're not it's not actually a
complete vaccine mandate and that's fine
i mean it's uh it's not my call so i'm
grateful for the people that provide us
this opportunity and
and uh the show went off without a hitch
right but it's just that you know joe
biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses has been the subject of
criticism and that's even less stringent
than the one at fox news right it
requires weekly testing as opposed to
daily testing so i'm curious as to why
you have an issue with the joe biden
vaccine mandate right but no problem
with the one at fox news beautiful
what do you want me to say
well
answer the question say for example well
uh
i'm doing it to get clicks
or it's a
them what to do
the government shouldn't be telling them
what to do
every company has its own policies and i
am beyond grateful for the opportunity
to work fox news channel and it does
things
that no other organization does
including your organization
so now he just goes into attacking the
the interviewer it's part of the trash
heap of left wing media
that does the same thing everyone else
does that's why we're number one i mean
i i can't even imagine what the clicks
are on your site is it like 15 people a
day like only journalists in new york
city they click on your that 16. good
they're the only people that read
mediaites actually people read read the
fox news channel so you guys want to
nitpick and do your thing it's cool but
it's funny to say it's nitpicking
to point out that fox news has been
waging a propaganda war against biden's
vaccine mandate while having a stricter
mandate for its own employees pete
hegseth calls that nitpicking uh i i
could not be more grateful for the fox
okay so there it is so he eventually
comes across something that sounds kind
of like an explanation which is hey
listen i'm fine with private companies
doing what they think is best but they
shouldn't be told by the government that
that's what they had to do but in in
getting to that explanation
he first has to attack media to get
there and insult them and say you guys
only get 15 clicks and this is this is
actually very common remember when
tucker carlson was confronted with the
same thing
his reaction was just as bizarre okay so
i i have a question here about fox news
um yeah
you said fox news has no vaccine mandate
but according to newsweek the company
requires unvaccinated employees to
submit to daily covid testing which is
stricter than biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing for businesses
that employ more than 100 people is fox
news denying the civil liberties uh of
its employees by being stricter than
president biden fair question i don't
know i mean you should probably ask
newsweek it sounds like they got a
pretty precise handle on what's
happening
hey
if it's wrong let me know if i'm wrong
yeah
it's
it's completely wrong as i noted the
other night
um i'm not
you know so what is the policy i'm not
going to tell you
to speak
for the company um on this because i
don't run the company and i'm not
you know i'm just gonna now that's very
disingenuous tucker could just speak to
his experience with the policy as an
employee he doesn't have to speak on it
as an employer it's very disingenuous
company um my personal preference is
that fox news
would you know make a statement about
what its policies are but i think like a
lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and
a lot with much higher mortality rates
than covid19
and you know there's hiv yeah so then as
a reminder he goes into kind of
comparing and equating
covet vaccination and covet to hiv which
is of course uh
an insane analogy given that hiv is
sexually transmitted you can't sneeze on
someone and give them hiv there's no
vaccine for hiv i mean
every time that they are actually
confronted with this
it's a fair question every time
they know that they're stuck in an
inconsistent position and they either
get angry and turn to insults or they do
what about ism so nice job there by
mediaites aidan mclaughlin and pete
hegseth looking kind of like a doofus i
must say
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right on monday i told you
some states
are looking very strongly
at going in the direction
of considering dropping mask mandates
either indoor at businesses and or
in schools over the last 48 hours since
i came to you with that report it is
accelerating dramatically more and more
localities more and more states talking
about no more masks as of some date in
the relatively near future could be
february it could be march and the
question now is is this the right time
not everybody agrees that it is i don't
actually have an answer and so anybody
trying to read into whether i think it's
time to end masking or not i'm not
completely sure i think there's
definitely a discussion to be had let's
go through some of the news um uh wabc
reporting
indoor masking coming to an end in new
york
is it hocal or hotel i never remember
hokel expected to make an announcement
wednesday
it is anticipated that the governor of
new york will announce the end of the
indoor mass mandate in new york state on
wednesday but the city mandate will
remain in place
the state mandate requires mass to be
worn inside businesses where vaccination
status was not being checked it is set
to expire thursday and the new york
times reports that the governor will
rescind it
um connecticut and new jersey are
already among a handful of states with
plans to ease mass mandates in schools
the governor of new york has not made
the same move
however she held a call with school
superintendents who believe an
announcement is coming soon
the governor is expected to extend the
mass mandate past its february 21st
expiration and through winter break
meanwhile
illinois is expected to announce an end
or rollback of certain mask rules cnn
reporting the governors of new york and
illinois are expected to announce the
end of or a plan to roll back
certain cove mitigation requirements
involving masks today i already told you
about new york in illinois governor jb
pritzker will likely announce wednesday
a path for ending the state's indoor
mass mandate in most public places
there is also increasingly pressure
in massachusetts on the governor charlie
baker to make some kind of uh off-ramp
type statement
many cities and towns already going in
that direction in california
california's indoor mass mandate will
end next week
for vaccinated people citing a 65
percent drop in covet cases since the
peak of omicron california will end its
statewide indoor mass mandate for
vaccinated individuals next week
governor gavin newsom announced monday
on february 15 california's statewide
indoor mass requirement will expire
unvaccinated people must still wear
masks indoors less than 20 percent of
the state's population remain
unvaccinated according to data the biden
administration has not yet offered a
plan or roadmap for how to handle this
so a couple different things here number
one not everybody agrees about this one
example is the former surgeon general
jerome adams now
jerome adams was not exactly the voice
of reason uh when the donald trump was
president so there are people who would
say
i don't care what jerome adams says but
jerome adams tweeting quote i
respectfully disagree with many of my
colleagues who are espousing the idea
that prematurely dropping mask mandates
will somehow make it easier to bring
them back if and when things get worse
again how'd that work out when cdc said
vaccinated could unmask last summer
he went on to say how do i define
premature well by looking at spread
impact and protection spread seven day
average still highest since april of
last year
impact over 2500 deaths yesterday
protection only 22 of those 5 to 11 and
56 percent of 12 to 17 year olds are
vaccinated exit the highway early
trip takes longer
i'm not sure if this is the right thing
to do or not
on the one hand jerome adams is right
which is the numbers are still not
looking great
that being said
we know
that the numbers significantly lag what
is going on there are states with cases
down 85 to 90 percent
vaccines are so widely available
the death rate is so incredibly low for
the vaccinated that the there becomes a
question of what is the milestone and if
there is not a reversal if we say well
cases are down in the country about 70
percent
in some states they're down 85 to 90
percent if we give it one more month and
and that continues and there isn't a
reversal
there really won't be anything else to
wait for in the sense that it's not
going away
anytime soon there's going to be a low
level again if in the next month there's
not a new variant that causes cases to
spike in a month cases will be
really at what we might call an endemic
level doesn't mean that the cases are
mild it might or it might not but we're
talking about the case levels
there's a question of what would we be
waiting for at that point in time
and there's not really a clear answer
and so that's where the if not in two to
four weeks then when
becomes a relevant question
um people who choose to remain
unvaccinated do so at their own risk and
as always the question then becomes what
about the immunocompromised
and um
that is a situation where those folks
say well i've gotten vaccinated
but
i still really can't do anything because
i might still catch it and i'm at higher
risk and that's a serious question i
mean a lot of those people haven't been
doing anything anyway so
it is a sort of chicken egg thing where
if the immuno-compromised folks that
have been staying home all this time
are already staying home
then
what is the reason to delay ending the
mask mandates for those who are not
staying home it's complicated i'm going
to admit that it's very complicated but
the question i keep coming back to is
if not in a month then what is the
milestone that we are waiting for and
i've not heard a good answer to that
which suggests
continuing on with some of this stuff
the school's question is a separate
question
particularly when in schools you've got
a population that has a lower
vaccination rate
um
i'm thinking out loud along with you
guys and i know that in my audience
there are people who are saying
this is it it's time for the personal
responsibility phase end everything and
let people decide for themselves what
level of risk to accept like we do
during flu season some people already
would wear a mask during flu season or
stay home that's one side of my audience
the other side of my audience says do
nothing we need to keep masking for at
least the entire year
we should be closing schools we should
so so i know that there's different
sides in my audience and i'm curious to
hear from you find me on twitter at d
pacman and let me know
what you think should happen now
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i was going to talk to you guys today
about the so so let me back up
a week ago i imagined that today i would
be talking to you about the u.s
anti-vaccine mandate trucker convoy
heading to washington dc set to arrive
today
their plan was to get to dc on the day
of joe biden's state of the union
address a week ago i thought i'd be
talking to you about it i'm not because
nobody's paying attention to it and it's
not even clear that it seems to have
sort of disintegrated and
one aspect of this is brought up in this
voicemail and our voicemail number again
is 2192 david p which is what mandates
are they protesting anyway take a listen
hi david listen i have a question for
you after all the mandates pretty much
been overturned by the courts except for
you know by these federal ones in the
service and at the airports and stuff
everything else is pretty much been
overturned by the court am i wrong
so why are the conflicts still forming
and still trying to make their way
across america now they got bikers doing
it too
and
they have much further cause why don't
they just take up their guns and go to
ukraine kyle rittenhouse to go with him
too he wanted to protect a storefront
let him protect a country with their
patriotism that trump calls them all
patriots but they're true patriots it's
gonna be something patriotic even if it
is for another country at least it shows
they got involved yeah so listen a
couple thoughts on the u.s trucker
convoy first of all ima and i tweeted
about this yesterday and many of you
wrote back
absolutely loving it and saying you had
thought the same thing
imagine that you spend a month or six
weeks or however long it was
organizing this convoy of truckers that
wants to protest vaccine mandates and
government tyranny and authoritarianism
and you're going to drive across the
entire country i don't remember where
they started whether it was california
or arizona somewhere in the southwest or
maybe texas who the hell even knows
they're gonna drive to washington dc
and then
quite literally as they're about to
leave to start their convoy
russia invades ukraine and gets 24 7
coverage and no one pays attention to
your stupid convoy so like that's number
one and that's funny and i genuinely
take pleasure in it that's hilarious
nobody's paying attention to these
people because russia has invaded
ukraine but then there are other layers
of absurdity that are
kafkaesque in this entire thing the
second one is
the whole premise of the trucker convoy
is that these are victims of tyranny and
authoritarianism right we are being
victimized by the tyrannical government
mostly state governments that say hey
you got to be vaccinated against kovid
and
quite literally russia invades ukraine
and people start dying
and the president of ukraine is out
there fighting and you as a trucker are
trying to say i'm a victim of tyranny
when you see what's going on in ukraine
beyond parody okay so that's like the
second layer that's that's funny or you
know curious and then of course the
third one is what the caller is saying
what mandates are you protesting so the
general biden vaccine mandate which by
the way wasn't a mandate because incur
it include or allowed for a test out
option you can opt out and test instead
that was blocked by a court
you then have states and municipalities
that have various vaccine requirements
you got to be vaccinated to work in a
healthcare setting or you've got to show
a vaccine card to go to a restaurant or
whatever they're mostly dropping it
because why it was an imaginary slippery
slope all along as covid is waning for
now fortunately and who knows what the
future holds variance spikes resurgence
cases are down 95 percent
and exactly as the same people expected
as the threat from covid goes down
various requirements are being
eliminated there's barely any mask
requirements left yes you gotta wear
masks on airplanes uh there's some some
cities and places that but the mask
requirements are going away the vaccine
requirements are going it's all going
away so what are you even protesting at
this point it's really an example this
entire u.s the canadian convoy was this
but the u.s trucker convoy is even more
so this
what are you protesting at this point
what on earth are you protesting and
they're just desperate for attention
which they're not getting thankfully
not thankfully that russia invaded
ukraine but thankfully as a result of
there being real news in the world
nobody's paying attention to that stupid
convoy and i'm absolutely loving every
minute of it we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today first of all
what would it look like
if ukraine joined the european union how
would it work what would it look like
and
what would be putin's reaction we're
going to talk about ukraine and the eu
on today's bonus show secondly
hackers
have been very involved in the russian
invasion of ukraine taking down a number
of prominent russian websites
uh and doing a whole bunch of other
stuff and one of the recent things that
happened is that 120 000 russian
soldiers have been doxed by hackers
meaning that their identities and their
personal information has been released
and
we're going to talk about obviously that
is is not in the realm of what we
typically consider cyber warfare
but where does that type of thing fit in
in uh international military conflicts
there are differing opinions it might
sound like no no no here's the here's
the one view on doxing soldiers and its
validity but there are actually some
dissenting views on that we're going to
talk about that and then number three
yesterday i told you that fifa has
determined russia
uh russian players can play in the world
cup but no russian national anthem and
they can't be identified as russia
that's been canceled russia has now been
totally thrown out of the world cup fifa
has decided they're just it's just a
hard no and we're going to talk about
that and other kind of
sports related sanctions that have come
in the past and that may come in the
future all of those stories and more are
on two days bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
simple
sign up for a membership at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code please don't war i know it sounds
ungrammatical but that's what it is the
coupon code is please don't war you'll
get a discount off of a membership
you'll get access to the bonus show the
commercial free audio feed the
commercial free video feed and much much
more we will see you then and tonight
live
on youtube twitch and facebook for joe
biden's state of the union address i
hope you'll join me i will see you then
you